okay so uh this one's been the eleven in
the room forever most people love it
some people hate it
but let's talk about talk about it and
uh
it's the driver monitoring in one pilot
uh i'll just call it dm uh for the rest
of the talk
here are the topics i would like to
cover today
to hopefully demystify commerce camera
based dm approach
let's start with the basics
so what's the goal of dm
what are we trying to achieve a bit
as we all know comma is uh proud about
shipping
a very good like uh level 2 system
and
as the system is getting better and
better we need to remind people that
they always need to pay attention a in a
level two system
uh to your uh to your driving
surroundings therefore the direct goal
of the dm is to keep the driver engaged
and obviously by using the camera only
driving now becomes more true because
the driver now doesn't doesn't need to
touch the wheel every now and then
when the system is engaged
when we say keeping the driver engaged
it means to make sure the driver is
always paying attention to the role that
they should be always to uh be ready to
take over
uh some examples of not being not paying
attention includes uh on your being on
your phone falling asleep or sim or even
like simply by just looking at the car
nestling for like too long
now that we have the problem in mind
let's fast forward and take a quick peek
at what uh comma
dm has achieved so far by looking at
some
numbers
you got here
uh the first one is a comparison part
between having dm and odm uh showing the
cumulative
the plot shows the accumulated
distributions between
of destruction durations between
the current dm current data and the data
we had before we shipped
open
operator dm
the green line is from recent feed data
and the orange line is from running the
same model and the data we had before dm
was shipped
both lines show when both lines show
data when the own palette is engaged
only
if we zoom into that
that section there in recent data 99.7
of the distracted events are less than
five seconds
while in the old data this number is
97.1 plus 2.4
which means dm has managed to reduce
distractions more
distractions more than five seconds by
ninety percent
which is substantial
here's another interesting step so at
run time dm is only like active when
open pilot is engaged but how about when
it's not engaged
by assuming dm is always alive we can we
ran the policy and the model applying on
all the logs to compare the amount of dm
alerts each user we have gotten per
minute both engaged and not engaged as
shown here
so the results show that when open pilot
is engaged drivers get sixty percent
less alerts on average on average when
compared to when they are driving
themselves thus we can say that when
engaged with open pilot people pay sixty
sixty percent more
attention in the sense that dm helps
them helps to remind people that
they need to be paying attention it's
not the fact that um that it beeps in
the fact is the fact that you know it
will beep at you if you don't pay enough
attention in a way it's similar to like
speed limits say it's not about like the
pres it's not about the consequences
it's mostly about the presence
which brings us to this graph to sum
things up dm basically achieved two
things
one is that it reminds people when
they're getting distracted without
actually knowing being distracted the
other one more importantly is that it
keeps people from evolving in distracted
behaviors in the first place
so how does so how does everything work
we start by looking at uh what happens
in open pilot
from sleeps to beeps
um so we have the driver the driver
facing camera that takes the picture of
the driver
say here with this beautiful comma free
camera
and then the picture is spec into a
neural network to estimate some
parameters of the driver we call these
parameters driver stage which includes
things like uh whether there's a face
where's the face where uh where are the
eyes are the eyes closed where the face
is looking at stuff like that
then we have a classical uh state
machine that takes in
the driver's state
all these parameters of the driver and
process them in loop as new pictures
comes in
come in
it also takes into account things like
the speed of the car
and also the how the camera is mounted
or even like how complex is the scene to
adjust all the things then the system
will use all these information to
determine whether the driver is being
too distracted and if they do an alert
will be shown
you've got the beeps
um of course the thing the brain of all
these is the the neural network model we
use to extract information from the
picture
now let's
do me more and look at the model itself
in like the more technical terms the
model is a efficient net v0 vision
network which which is eight bit
quantize to run on the dsp instead of
the gpu such that uh the dm model
doesn't compete we source compete for
resource with the driving model such
that they can both they can both have
room for growth say we want to train big
model in the future for both of them we
can do that
and the two main outputs will be the
driver's head post and i stage which are
the two cornerstones of open part dm
uh well uh
it may not seem much but as we shall
show here we we are we shall be showing
uh these two aspects are actually proven
to be quite versatile when it comes to
determining driver attention
here are a few examples of dm model in
action when i was driving
we can see that by just looking at
only the head and the eye you can
actually catch things from simply
looking away or playing with your phone
when driving or the the even more subtle
like falling asleep somehow
and of course the model works both day
and night
well
you might not wonder how the measly
8-bit model can do all these tricks as
george always said the most important
aspect of machine learning is of course
the data
so so the next talking point will be our
data
the latest dm model is trained with more
than 23 000 hours of driver videos
uploaded
from
over
1600
unique users unique users from our feed
fleet which is
uh which makes up roughly 20
25 of the total user space
uh thanks to them open pilot dm can be
as good as today
uh we would love to see this number this
number grow and in the coming slides i'm
going to show what we go what we are
doing with the data and
why more people should upload
well some people might be worried that
their faces will be looked at when we
label the data and thus have concerns
about privacy and stuff like that
and yes we do late we we do have our
diligent data labelers but they are
machines
so these beautiful computing clusters
that greg bill are also our dm labelers
here i have three pictures for them
because
we have three racks
so how are the ground shoes generated
um so we have been building this uh dm
data annotation pipeline for almost two
years now uh which can do the following
tasks in a fully automated manner so so
that no human no human would need to
look at the
data any of the data
here are some of the examples of our
auto ground shooting stack in action
where you can see faces being
detected and the pose being accurately
estimated and also
as well as the eyes and where whether
they're closed
so what's actually doing all these
things are what we call the t-shirt
models that we train separately
uh to work specifically on our data set
uh using a technique called transfer
learning which means the knowledge of
these models are obtained from somewhere
else
in this case it's the open source data
sets
so you have these open source data sets
of course you can not easily just train
some models on them but it won't work
because they don't like nothing
from our data
which brings us to the idea of a domain
adaptation
it means that we need to open
uh these open source data sets to make
them look
somewhat similar to our what's in our
data set then we can start training
models on them speaking of domain domain
adaptation
the idea can be also
be applied to say
when we want to train we train the model
that used to work on eons to work on
comma tools we can just make the we can
just start by making the eon pictures
pink kind of pinkish to mimic the ir
ir lighting in the comma tube
and it's also the same trick when we
want to transfer the say the comma two
models knowledge into uh
the comma free
oh sorry
into the comma three capable model
that's how we shipped uh really good uh
comma two
that's how we ship the
that's how we make the common free
dm model good at launch without actually
using a lot of common free data
so after all that labeling and training
now we move on to testing which is the
most integral part for us to move
forward and
avoid aggression regressions
so to test
you need a metric what is a good metric
for good dm experience is it model
accuracy does a high motor accuracy
equal to a good experience
well not necessarily
well that's not true for dm at all
actually usually like 99 would be fine
but but now you're assuming the one
percent back experience is evenly
disputed among all users
then in this case all users are enjoying
99
of the experience but in dm usually
99 means one percent of the users are
constantly suffering and having constant
constant force positive or something
like that where the m doesn't work for
them at all
so how do we catch them so to catch only
any of such bad
bad experiences we crunch numbers on
every device in the training set and
validation set
for example here we try to see
how often each device will get alerts
with some candidate model we want to
ship
each dot here
represents a bit device we can see some
device get a lot of dimmers consistently
and it's a and it's important that we
understand all these
positives
for example if this happens on me where
the model constantly thinks i'm
distracted why i'm not we need to find
out why
it could be because the model doesn't
work well enough when wearing glasses or
is it because the policy is too strict
because i squint too much into the sun
or something like that
these are the questions that inspire us
to write more detail tests and fix the
problems they exposed
[Music]
on the right uh is another example of
testing by worst cases according to this
distribution curve some devices are
constantly failing to detect bases why
is it due to the model not working in
certain lighting conditions or maybe
it's just the lenses covered we need to
we need to figure them out
so by visualizing all these worst cases
we can easily identify uh what some of
the problems are and what can be fixed
either by software or hardware
say for example uh
in the red ones they're clearly covered
and they're hopeless and then in the
black in the black images it's probably
because the ieds are broken and that's a
horror issue
so the takeaway is we can learn and
improve things a lot by just looking at
the worst cases
all right on top of everything i've
talked about so far i would like to also
ask some comments about thinking dm as a
machine learning problem in general
so we currently have data
uploads from about 1600 users
and below is the amount of people who
don't
who from who we don't get the dm data
from which is 75 75 of all users
which means for us as a company we are
stuck with this small subset of date of
data to build a system which is expected
to work on the ma on a much larger user
base than the training set size
well
now all this looks like a disaster for
overfitting especially when when you
have shown that even 99 isn't good
enough
in other words the model is only
guaranteed to perform well on the people
who's in the training set
what's the solution then hmm
well
how about
more people consider uploading their
driver camera maybe
wow it's just an inform recommendation
absolutely nothing more than that
right seriously though turn on turn it
on
to help yourself and help others
now let's move on to
what's next
apparently the next
big thing would be end-to-end dm where
we will move the boundary between
perception and reasoning like we did in
the driving model the dm model will have
only one
output called ison row
unlike like
in the classical model where we output
like
many parameters of the driver and did a
lot of uh complex math and then and
figure out whether it's distracted or
something
and actually we are now actively working
on getting automatic wank through
working on this uh end-to-end pipeline
um
pretty exciting stuff
also to give the model more context we
are also considering making it temporal
or turning back models on the common
freeze 180 model to make it see more
so yeah there are so many
potential big improvements we can make
to stay ahead of the dm game
very exciting stuff
that's it from me today thanks for
listening
[Applause]
all right
how many of you are going to turn your
driver monitoring
toggle on
right
all right here we go jason
thanks this is a lot of good info can
you talk a little bit more you said
there were times when the dm model would
kind of
relax versus tighten up its requirements
for paying attention is that more than
just stopped versus not stopped right
now
so in the driving model
in the driving model it outputs
the probability of you like being
engaged and also the probability of you
like disengage in so many seconds in the
future so we use all the information to
like
like adaptively set the threshold based
on the scene complexity that the model
thinks
like when it would fail
so that such that the dm model can be
more relaxed when say it's driving on a
straight highway compared to it's like
stuck in traffic
okay so every once in a while i see
someone question
you know i tried closing my eyes and the
dm model didn't do anything or i tried
doing this or that or i looked away and
it didn't detect anything and a good
explanation for that might be that it's
relaxed a little bit because this is a
simple scene with a low probability
according to the model of the driver
having to grab control
yeah would that be fair okay thank you
doesn't mean you can ever not pay
attention though
that's right
um my question is more about
uh future possibilities with the comma
three in the
180 degree field of view obviously there
was some questions about
a sentry mode and comma security and all
these things
do you think implementing some of those
features
into the official release of openpilot
may encourage with like a
prerequisite of needing to upload your
driver monitoring to record these events
could help
uh encourage more people to use that
feature and upload
because they're getting more benefit
from it
when right now they may just feel that
it's only a benefit for comma at a cost
of their privacy
where you could give them security at a
cost of their privacy and they may
consider it yeah so we are considering
that um
so actually
we are actually also considering using
the comma freeze 180 like driver camera
to
like to extract some of the like
information for driving
which is like the offering
like we can do
like you mentioned
so what we can do is like if we can
somehow make the users upload
with that
and if they if they don't like it they
can like choose to blur out their faces
then that would be great
quick question for you are you always
limited to using the dsp uh will the
open pilot team ever give you more
compute if you ask for it
and is there any difference between the
um c2s
qualcomm i think it's an 820 or 8 25 dsp
versus the c3 is 845. the c3s is way
better
but we are only using
say
10
maybe 12
potential on the c2 so there's a lot of
room for growth
got anything in the crowd alright we got
someone upstairs
no worries i gotcha
all right
uh you you mentioned transfer learning
from training on some general object
detection data sets with some kind of
augmentation are you doing like uh
self-supervised pre-training or could
you explain that a bit more
well you can do augmentations like
color
like mimicking or you can do like
something like fourier domain adaptation
to mimic like the sharpness
on like a finer level of the image to
make them more look like look more like
the ones on our data set
does that answer a question
and you aren't directly training the uh
efficient net you you're training a
teacher policy
yeah we first generate the ground
through using the the ground shoes using
the t-shirt networks on our data and
then we use our data and those labels to
train the efficient
to make the model perform
have you ever considered using a
monochrome ir camera it looks like there
is some color data maybe limited
use on
what we saw on the demos
um
we are not having problems with using
like
rgb ir cameras so i don't think that's a
limiting factor for us so far
so given that this is an opt-in are you
currently tracking the users who show
um a high
uh what's it called the the
distraction level on a consistent basis
and would you ever seek action to ban
those users is that a consequence no
oh
you want to put up with the b big i mean
you know you should not pay attention
you're an idiot
don't mess with your dm you mess with
your dm abandoned
hey so kind of a broad question so it's
totally understandable why you need to
like work on dm and and have some way to
like be able to alert the driver and
even help them and perhaps even hold
them accountable maybe that's taking it
too far but
but at the same time you also say stuff
like and i realize it's maybe half
joking like we're l2 we take no
accountability so i guess what you see
is the purpose of dm to the extent that
what i'm saying of the company not
taking any maybe i meant to say
liability instead of accountability i'm
not taking liability like
what's the purpose in light of that
[Music]
it's not
it's not like a liability level it's
more like
you want
the you want to remind the driver that
the limitation of the system and what
their
expectation of the system should be
but and by using dm we are ensuring
that concept is always present
does that answer the question i think so
thank you
um
since in the future you guys are going
to be using the front-facing camera for
the driving
portion of the of the
of the comma of open a pilot um are you
going to be doing two passes basically
um process a frame of
video for
driver monitoring and then
reprocess the frame again for the
driving or is it going to be all mended
into just one process
we'll see
so now we have the super combo maybe
there's a super super combo in the
future
using all three cameras
uh hello have you considered
incentivizing users to upload their
their video as a as an investment in
improving the overall effectiveness for
everybody
yes
i mean if you upload it works better on
you so i mean that's the
direct incentive
comma points obviously are very valuable
the more you have the more important you
are
all right that looks like it
all right
you